euromaxx highlights and here's your host
cayenne hempstead greetings from Berlin
once again and welcome to our highlights
of the past week which this time around
included in the following story time to
celebrate the legendary porsche 911
turns 50 time to speculate Britain
eagerly awaits the birth of a new royal
time to demonstrate how a new fun sport
is rolling through town over many car
enthusiasts it's the epitome of sports
car sick and the best way to get the
women to do a double take I'm talking
about the iconic Porsche 911 and its
combination of performance power and
poetry in motion is not just fact it's
legend this year the 911 model
celebrates its 50th anniversary and many
models later it's still a design icon
and a speedsters wildest dream was the
one day sunny did eventually get home
okay
these Porsche 911s can do zero to 100 in
a sweet five seconds and hit peak speeds
of 300 km/h although they do guzzle gas
at speeds like that
you're home Gausman has four different
911s filling the front passenger seat is
never a problem
he's been tight [ __ ] yarn I started 40
years ago on it's just a great car I'm
toilet outdoor the engine sound is
fantastic and the accelerator response
is superb driving this car is incredible
fun this year marks the 50th anniversary
of Porsches most famous car the
company's Museum and stood guard is
celebrating with an exhibition featuring
40 different models covering half a
century of 911 heritage Matthias color
joined the porsche design team 24 years
ago for color the original 911 remains
the ultimate edition that's me mr Wood
gough island had fun out skin ever since
I was a boy I really liked the 911 space
back then it was already leaving other
cars in the dust boarding upon when it
also looked fast thanks to its
dimensions and dynamic styling but it
was also a subtle conservative car the
combination of elegant sporting
proportions and functionality was a
winner for to navigate the porsche 911
first wild the world in 1963 when it was
unveiled in prototype form at the
frankfurt motor show it's been the
beating heart of the Porsche brand for
five decades in its seven successive
generations the 911 has sold a total of
over 800 thousand units worldwide over
the years its sportscar credentials have
also been proven on the track with
triumphs at the monte carlo rally and
the 24 Hours of the mall
for journalists hands your guts or the
key to the speedsters popularity is its
versatility as I'm gonna isn't the
marriage of performance and practicality
is a crucial factor you can use this car
to get to work every day or take the
kids to school but you can also drive it
to the Arctic Circle wherever you go the
car is almost guaranteed to get you
there safely the thought of it seemeth
cause I was tryna start musica diamond
bling was originally the anniversary
exhibition also showcases the latest
generation of the 911 mattyas cooler and
his team spent two years on the new
edition their efforts were recognized
with a prestigious red dot award for
design it's cool seein ya i know i'm not
if it looks like a 911 the side profile
the wide rear and the body shape are
those of a 911 he knows what's the
simplicity and bold look decaf tea
coffee dolphinia fun I'm proud of how we
managed to retain the DNA of the 911
while combining it with modern design
undersides of the artifice it's a
convenient yahan Grossman's 911 models
date from between 1986 and 2010 some of
them cost over 100,000 euros but for
true Porsche fans it's the inner values
that really count
this why sugimoto the white g model has
231 horsepower but it really packs a
punch when you step on it porsche
horsepower count double ok if you're
driving through torrential rain on the
outer bar you have to give preference to
cars like the audi quattro the porsche
does remain prone to aquaplaning
deletion in a club learning and philly
and filling his farts like the Porsche
911 a living legend among auto
enthusiasts
50 years and still ripping up the tarmac
while celebrations to mark Queen
Elizabeth's coronation 60 years ago were
going on this past week in London but
rather curiously there was another kind
of hype in the air namely at a special
service for the Queen at Westminster
Abbey the buzz of reporters that were
eager to get a look at the Duchess of
Cambridge or rather at her royal bump
otherwise known as Prince William's wife
Kate the Duchess is indeed carrying the
next royal baby and the upcoming birth
this July is the talk of the town in
London Martina is a huge fan of the
royal family she's been looking forward
to the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge's
first baby ever since the pregnancy was
announced last year
I think it's going to be the most
marvelous thing when we have Kate and
William's first baby I think the country
the world is going to go mad it's the
most important baby in the world and
it's not here yet her modest home in a
London suburb the self-styled heritage
house contains an enormous collection of
over 10,000 royal mementos her passion
for oil memorabilia began over 30 years
ago the collection ranges from cups and
plates to cardboard cutouts and
photographs the new baby souvenirs will
take pride of place right next to her
William and Kate dolls
the first souvenir will be a mug because
I love China and a plate I hope and you
know just general China obviously we
don't know yet whether a pink one or a
blue and if anybody was sending pink and
blue and I would buy one of each because
I know then I've got it right somewhere
Portland manufacturer Hudson and
Middleton is working at full capacity to
cope with the demand for themes china
cups the gender and name of the baby
have to wait until a big day of course
but the mug prototypes are already
finished in both blue and pink for the
Royal baby we have got orders currently
of about six to eight thousand and so
really we are looking to do something
like fifty thousand pieces in a very
short window of about a month
Hudson and Middleton was founded in
stoke-on-trent in eighteen seventy five
this is the heart of the potteries
region of the english midlands named
after the many ceramics companies that
were founded here in the 17th century
although many have gone factory chimneys
still feature prominently on Stokes
skyline Hudson and Middleton combines
traditional craftsmanship with modern
technology it's 40 strong work force
turns out 8,000 items are China a week
in a variety of designs the new
commemorative mark presents a one
potential headache for the makers though
the baby having an inconveniently long
name or names it could test us it could
be a situation where we have to shrink
the size of the print or even consider a
bigger beaker if we get we end up with
an enormous amount of names but normally
what would happen is we can always put
initials for some of the names if we
have to the bookmakers in Britain famous
for giving odds on everything imaginable
have seen a flurry of bets on the baby's
name among the current favorite are
Alexandra Elizabeth Diana Victoria and
George
but it's not only the name that people
are betting on anything from the hair
color of the baby to how much the baby's
gone away maybe when it's born or even
the day or time that the baby's gonna be
born and then a couple funny ones like
wherever it's going to be maybe a
cesarean or a natural birth and the
magazine that get the first official
rights are the first photos and the baby
is not just an issue of interest for
those who fancy a flutter I think it's
very uplifting for all the country you
know and it's something that's very much
needed you know I think it's exciting
and she seems like she'll be an amazing
mobile the Royals are not really
something which I think about very often
so I guess not not really not much
excitement Margaret Tyler is very
excited she already has plans for the
big day
I think I will have a little baby party
I don't drink myself only drink tea but
you know other people can drink
champagne and wet the baby's head and as
such a joyous occasion I mean a new
babies lovely in any family but this is
special because it's a future king or
queen and it's a very for such a small
baby it's a lot isn't it for this royal
collector extraordinaire the arrival of
the future heir to the throne can't come
soon enough well at this point in the
show I don't normally take a seat but
then I don't usually have such a nifty
little stool at my disposal and if you
think that this is any ordinary stool
then I'd have to ask you to think again
well beyond its relatively pleasant and
somewhat understated design because
there are some people for whom a stool
like this is a regular workout and
certainly a whole lot of fun so
introducing the sport occur or sports
stool made in Germany and really on a
roll slide freeze leapfrog
hydrol combination these tools weren't
just made for sitting thousands of young
people have discovered this new fun
sport now they get together the world
over to practice just like here in
Berlin
they're funny 15 I've at first I thought
it looked silly the way they were
juggling their stools but I had lots of
fun and stuck with it there are so many
tricks you can learn by ivalice all
philosophy no tricks give Lord these
muffins and touts the people who do it a
very open and curious there are always
such exciting people for include isn't
/span in the Lord altima macaca whenever
I do it everybody looks and asks what
this is about they start talking and
it's a chance for me to tell them about
it it's special this is Wes was on
little
juggling with stools originated in the
circus this new sport takes things a
step further incorporating elements of
modern breakdance
mejia Lynch Devin lund shoots are among
its pioneers everyone competitions and
set world records and they reinvented
the stool as sports equipment
in 2007 the two product designers came
up with a durable stool ideally suited
for their often daring acrobatics they
made it available as the sport hawker
featuring a range of graphics for retail
prices of 90 260 euros
their idea to turn a simple plastic
stool into a piece of sports equipment
has won a number of prizes
I think this one is robust this one
isn't it a break right away it's made a
very brittle plastic that's it this is
relatively lightweight it won't break
plus it's hard to grip this one but as
you see this one is very easy to grab
those guns life's too clever size does
come tonight I can lift it with one
finger but not this one I can jump on it
and do all kinds of stuff handstands
whatever I want and it won't break let's
move you on this book this cup with you
recently the brothers started touring
Europe performing in such major cities
as Rome they present a new sport as a
street performance videotaping each
other and posting the videos on the
internet
you know stuff every city is different
rome isn't madrid in madrid isn't London
every city has its own character
different places have different steps
blocks and Heights and they inspire more
new tricks that's the great thing about
it basically you can do it anywhere and
this inspiration has helped to develop
and spread the sport rapidly yeah I
wanted a vital Berlin stages Europe's
biggest youth sports and lifestyle trade
fair Stephan and we share lunch hoods
have been there promoting the sport
hawkers and the sport that goes with
them it's not easy to learn the first
tricks beginners are always a bit of
wobbly on their stools
I think they look really cool I'm
totally interested in what they're doing
it looks really awesome and I'd like to
do it but it must be pretty hard to miss
you this thing
it's hard to keep your balance on it
it's something you and you sports a fun
it's kind of fun and it's a challenge to
learn a trick like this this board isn't
about mastering all the moves perfectly
spot hoppin is more about getting
together practicing tricks and being
outside well up to Norway now where
they're celebrating a happy occasion for
a master of melancholy the expressionist
painter Edvard monk is that country's
most famous artist and his masterpiece
The Scream is an image that has been
copied countless times a monk was born
150 years ago and now an anniversary
double exhibition in Oslo illuminates
the darkness of his vision it's an
iconic image known the world over The
Scream painted by Edvard monk in 1893
one of the key paintings of the
expressionist movement it captures monks
goal of creating works that are a study
of the soul Norway is currently
celebrating the 150th anniversary of
monks birth a commemorative exhibition
as being held at oslo's national gallery
and the monk museum with 250 exhibits in
all it's the most comprehensive
retrospective of the artists work to
date
Niels Olson from Germany is one of the
curators movies wouldn't own a milk is
still very relevant for us today he's
accessible and every day we have
hundreds of visitors who try to imitate
the scream but he also continues to have
a massive influence on contemporary art
he's a highly experimental artists who
always drew on his own life for his work
and considered they also I ignant Liam
shift that meant considering difficult
themes such as illness fear morning and
death the artist lost his mother at a
young age and his older sister Sophie
whom he adored died of tuberculosis monk
himself struggled with alcoholism in one
important work entitled the sick child
milk breaks with realism to take on his
sister's death hunt Martin flattened is
an art historian and an expert on Edward
monk he takes us on a tour of monks Oslo
this place is removed and his family
lived between 1885 and 1889 and we
painted too I was lamaze to pieces here
the sick child between 1885 and 1886 and
also spring in eighteen eighty nine and
this was a working-class area of town
and MOOCs father was a doctor he worked
in the military but they also serve the
population around
this is the district of granola where
monk grew up after a year a technical
college he decided to devote himself to
art
the church the role house is going up
the hill that you see right behind me it
was the first test subject chosen by
moon Kevin a was 18 years old and I
decided to become a serious artist and
the view was the one he could see from
his family so flat just across the river
this is the apartment block where a drug
mom grew up with his brother and three
sisters in a very religious family now
we are our own Ichabod and in the
background we can see the view of Oslo
and in MOOCs most famous picture to
scream you can see a similar simplified
view so this is something well known to
people and move sort of turned that
around and make did something horrible
and frightening loneliness and despair
take on a sensory dimension a scream
escapes from the canvas a sound captured
for our eyes
desh hai is in Mozilla the screen was
stolen from the museum in 2004 it caused
a huge interest in the media a version
of the painting was auctioned off in New
York last year it's currently the most
expensive painting worldwide it's partly
thanks to the media that this work has
become iconic the cornish of Oliver Kahn
the screen is one of the world's most
famous paintings and the anniversary
exhibition in Oslo shows why Edward
monks masterpiece continues to captivate
us to this day well speaking of
captivating there were nifty new
furniture designs to be seen at the
annual d my design festival in Berlin
it's the biggest event of its kind here
in Germany and this year more than 500
exhibitors from 30 nations took part the
special focus was on Poland and this
allowed polish design talent both
established and newcomer to attract some
international attention and so we caught
up with one young duo from Gdansk whose
career already looks to be into smooth
sailing furniture made from sail cloth
is waterproof inflatable and mobile
these designs are by agata Coolican
pavel poem or ski from Gdansk the
husband-and-wife team worked together as
the designer duo mala for lab lab Louis
with our furniture is inspired by the
traditional sail cloth of this region
there are lots of workshops here in
Gdansk that make the best sales for
customers around the world we produce
our chairs and sofas in the same
tradition not only do we use the same
material the seams and joins are also
made in the same way as argued
it takes about a minute for the limp
material to become design objects for
the living room they're inspired by the
beach and a maritime lifestyle Agatha
Cooley camp evoke primorsky live in the
countryside [ __ ] dansk this is where
they design their furniture with this
small addition a standard ladder can be
converted into an elevated thrown the to
seek to blend functionality with a touch
of irony is we need to assume we're not
interested in regular wooden chairs Paul
on there no we charge our stools no
charge it's gonna pop up here we don't
make normal sofas either go to y'all's
own music we make some out of paper or
sail cloth Washington we like to play
with contrasts from we design but we
still take our job is designer as
seriously the furniture must be
functional that's the main thing but
there's always some kind of ingenuity on
the plate pavan yet downstairs in the
workshop Pavel / morskie is working on
the latest project this structure is a
custom design for the port city of
Gdynia near Gdansk and is made for
bathers to relax on as they float on the
sea
creative designers from around the world
are currently meeting at the former
tempelhof airport in Berlin it's the
annual d my design festival this year
Poland is the focus so of course
malifaux are making an appearance it was
important for us to come here as so many
products from Poland are being shown
here in Berlin now everyone can see that
design is also important to us in Poland
so if I keep my foot on it are a fact no
better be 40 polish designers were
invited to the festival never before
have so many designers from Poland
displayed works in Germany at the same
time visitors are making new discoveries
like these tools by design label tab
under or this coat stand by Tamara
garlic also history has historically
Poland has been more of a place for
production rather than design in the
last two or three years we've seen the
design industry becoming more important
for Poland and more and more polish
designers are working for international
companies in internet seen islands I
name are biting over the past few years
polish economic growth has been surging
yeah cops chase Lee works in Warsaw as
an architect and designer for a growing
number of affluent customers
it's only now in the last couple of
years that people start to need polish
things and they feel a pride of having
their own polish designs not expensive
Italian sofas so it's probably some
moment in the development of of our
society many young creative people are
now moving to the port city of diced and
its neighboring coastal towns pavel poem
or ski and Agatha kulick themselves
studied at the dance academy of fine
arts mumble of your search for the mega
team our customers are excited about
design their German French Italian or
Spanish but very few were polish when
you think we can change that by
designing nice things and getting
involved in interesting projects Santa
mcfish is a movie break the line y WP in
2012 mala for won the red dot award for
their sofa the duo stand for new
innovative design from Poland
and a salute from the beach that's all
for this edition of our highlights
thanks very much for watching and hope
you'll be tuning in next time around
until then all the best ass in Berlin
entries